I say like if you accomplish nothing  else in your life but to heal and not  pass that on you're actually  demonstrating a principle of healing to  the whole planet if it could happen to  you it can happen to everybody it can  happen to the planet if you're shifting  reality into alignment with your own  healing by healing and the same yeah on  a planetary collective level the same  principle operates so all of these  negative forces all these dark forces  they are actually rendering an  evolutionary service to the galaxy or to  the cosmos by creating the conditions  for this healing to even have have to  happen yeah yeah